laissez parler la présidente
non vous me dites
donc monsieur le Président après le
recours au 47 ans par le gouvernement
pour examiner ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
rectificative la commission des affaires
sociales a pris la décision de rejeter
tous les sous amendements que nous avons
déposé et les a examinés à une vitesse
je dois dire et claire sans tenir compte
de ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire que des sous amendements
ont aussi donc rejeté alors que les
amendements les mêmes les mêmes qui les
mêmes amendements ont été obtenus en
leur temps lors des travaux de la
commission des affaires
sociales donc j'ai une question moi cela
veut simplement dire que le Sénat ne
veut pas débattre de l'article 7 qui est
pourtant
le cœur du texte et le sujet le sujet
d'allongement de l'âge et des parts à la
retraite qui préoccupe des millions de
nos concitoyens et de nos concitoyens
comme on l'a vu aujourd'hui dans la rue
et les jours précédent et comme on le
verra encore samedi prochain donc vous
refusez le débat démocratique et
sincèrement monsieur le Président je
pense et vous me connaissez je pense que
ça ne mord pas notre institution ça
n'honore pas le Sénat et je veux vous le
dis aussi crûment que ça nous refusons
de participer à cette entomine et nous
quittons l'hémicycle ce soir et nous
reviendrons demain